never look
back hacks and simply learn to get ahead
Jess Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
or with a course from a premier
University Direction true champion who
upskilled to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get
ahead simply learn from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time career
transformation bro simply learn industry
expert
live data
difficult with a well structured course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that long didn't choose a quick fix he
just added data science into the
mix Nan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint a regular
job responsibilities but nothing could
stop nathin from getting ahead what an
allrounder de Hoya night with flexible
learning you can always always make it
right passion
situation you two will find your way to
get ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead withn uh
we'll be starting the free interview
prep past class in few minutes uh
meanwhile I'm just putting down my
introduction here on chat here so hello
fabulous people Russia here all the way
from Bangalore India I'm thrilled to be
your host today and you can drop us a
hello on the chat here and let us know
where are tuning in from uh let the
global conversations begin uh before we
start uh so we can just introduce
ourselves on chat here uh put on your
name and where you're joining us from
it's a good way to network right these
events so before we start in few minutes
please do introduce yourself on chat
here and also sometimes you're not able
to make out your name from the username
here so you can tell us your name as
well you know as you're comfortable so
uh we'll start in few minutes uh
meanwhile I can see the Productions
coming in on chat here that's great uh I
can see Natalia has joined from Atlanta
I can see uh trishra has joined from mer
hey hi everyone welcome welcome for
welcome everyone uh thank you for
joining us we'll be starting in few
minutes uh I can see DGA has joined DGA
where are you joining us from I can see
talisi has joined I can see anamik has
joined from uh Mumbai and uh I see more
introductions coming in on chat here so
folks who have just joined right now uh
just to let you know that I'm Rasha Khan
I'm your host for today's webinar and
I'm joining from all the way from
Bangalore India and I'm thrilled to be a
host today uh you can drop us a hello on
chat here you can let us know where are
you joining from do mention your name as
well some we are not able to sometimes
make out your name from the email ID
which is
visible so we'll be talking about how
you can crack the code on how to e a
blockchain interview uh would love to
know how many blockchain enthusiasts
here chat
here okay I can see folks are joining in
uh right now and meanwhile folks who
have already joined please get settled
in wherever you're joining us from so
good evening good afternoon uh good
morning wherever you're joining us from
I can see folks have joined from
indor uh Tamil Nadu I can see gir Prasad
has joined from Pune Diva has joined
from kpur vut has joined from Bangalore
Anita has joined from South Africa and
Vishnu hi Vishnu let us know where are
you joining us
from I can see Puja has joined from
baramati awesome awesome keep the
introductions coming in we'll be
starting in few minutes uh before we
start let's go go through the ground
rules uh meanwhile you know folks are
joining in so uh if you have a question
for our speaker here with us speak
speaker which who's already here with us
vja Yuri uh who's a blockchain expert uh
you can put down your questions in the
Q&A box and we'll be having a special
duration for the Q&A box so in case we
are not able to take your questions so
don't worry we'll take it towards the
end uh the session is being recorded in
case you want to go through the
recording of the session once again in
case you miss something out so you can
expect a followup email with this
recording link weinar certicate and also
the bonus offer for attending this
webinar so the bonus offer is for the
program by it canor which we'll be
talking about after the interview of
theaster
class and also uh about the webinar
certificate uh you need to stay till the
end of the session for basically getting
the certificate of this webinar uh so
about the recording as I said that you
basically be getting a recording as well
so uh again like welcome everyone um
awesome to have you here I can see the
introduction still coming in we have
gotten a really active and warm audience
here uh keep the introductions coming in
I'll just take you through the agenda
quickly and meanwhile folks who have
just joined right now it's fantastic to
have you on board so welcome once again
uh so agenda starting with the agenda
we'll be getting to know uh more about
you exactly how we can help you out in
your blockchain interview preparation
and we'll be talking we'll be taking you
through the blockchain interview prep we
have something very exciting lined up
for you and uh then about the pro
program introduction of professional
certificate program in blockchain by IIT
kpur and also taking you to the
enrolling steps of that program and also
special duration for the Q&A as I
mentioned earlier so the Q&A box is just
beside the chat box where we are having
a lot of interesting introductions here
so you can just navigate and uh check
out the Q&A box just beside the chat uh
so we get a lot of messages on chat here
so we will miss your question here your
query here whichever bit and we would
love to address all of your queries so
please just help us out by just putting
down your questions in the Q&A box and
I'll make sure that your questions are
answered by the speaker here and also
please keep it related to blockchain
because this session is about blockchain
here so moving on so before we start as
I said that we'll be getting to know a
little bit about you so uh please tell
us like how many years of experience do
you currently have so you can see a
quick poll on your screen here which has
very uh easy four quick options here the
first one currently studying second one
0 to three years of experience third one
3 to 5 years of experience and the last
one more than five years of experience
so you can choose the one which is the
most suitable for you in terms of
experience
and in case you don't have that option
which is the most suitable for you can
let us know in chat here as well that's
also okay so I can see introductions are
still coming in that's great I'll just
do one thing I'll just introduce myself
on chat once again I am Rasha and I'm
joining from Bangalore
India for folks who have just joined
right now we are just starting the
session and uh we're just starting with
a quick poll you can see on the screen
here while I was speaking we already
have gotten almost 80% of the votes here
uh in the poll so that's great uh I can
see the audience will pretty active here
and I'll just give five seconds for this
poll more uh while you're basically
choosing the most suitable options
here awesome awesome uh I think I'll
just give 5 Seconds more for few of the
folks who have not shared their
responses to the poll here yet so how
many years of experience do you
currently have so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and also share the
letters with you thank you so much for
sharing that with us uh so as we can see
that 40% of the folks who have joined us
are currently studying uh 37% of the
folks have three Z to three years of
experience and I can see a few of the
folks have more than five years of
experience and uh some of them have
three to five years of experience so
thank you so much once again for sharing
that with us now moving on we already
have a speaker here with us visha Kum
Yuri visha would you like to give us
your introduction to the crowd here yeah
sure RHA hi everyone uh very good
evening I see people from all over the
world here yeah yeah so uh my name is
visha and I am working as a blockchain
developer uh you can uh see there my
initial experience is around three plus
years and I into the blockchain space
from 2017 itself so yeah I was into the
all the uh evolving era of
blockchain uh from Bitcoin from ethereum
and from nfds and now the current is
tokenization so I'm working on the asset
tokenization part yeah so coming to my
educational background I have done my
btech uh in CSC and I'm pursuing my
mtech from I partner oh interesting nice
uh we have gotten an I here so uh so
thank you so much visha for a great
introduction here and again like once
again welcome uh welcome to the
interview Master Class of blockchain and
we are looking forward to this exciting
session of as we can see that you have
so much experience you have started from
you know when basically Bitcoin started
and blockchain basically came in later
so I think we have a lot to learn from
you and I'm pretty sure you have so many
interesting experiences of your
interview which we'll be talking about
more in the upcoming slides uh so once
again folks uh so while we be talking
about the interview questions we'll be
taking some interesting questions you
know of interviews and talking about you
know how you can answer them V will be
sharing you know few tips on that as
well from his own experiences it so what
you can do is you can put down your
questions in the Q&A box if you have any
questions about the blockchain interview
General uh career in general so we'll
try to take those questions you know
during uh those uh interview prep
sessions as well so uh moving
on uh before we start uh we would love
to know that why are you attending this
interview master class today so you can
I'll just uh launch this quick poll here
uh yeah you can see this quick poll here
on your screen uh this is to understand
why exactly are you attending this
interview Master CL prep master class
today uh basically what exactly are you
looking for uh through this interview PP
Master Class you can see four quick
options here uh this one is a multiple
choice question so you can select
multiple options because there can be
multiple reasons right for attending
this webinar today so uh and ALS also if
this options don't cover your basically
answer here you can let us know on chat
here as well so that is also totally
okay so I would love to folks here to
share basically their insights their
thoughts on chat here and U basically
keep the conversations engaging on chat
here uh basically talk with the speaker
here so please do that uh we basically
would love to see your insights we would
love to hear your thoughts uh you can
share like her moment or her valuable
tip you related to today's topic which
behalf of blockchain interview prep and
also your insights might Inspire others
in the chat you know to speak up so
please do that uh we would love to hear
what your thoughts are and I can see
while I was speaking folks have already
like shared uh responses on the poll
here most of them have done that so
that's great uh I think I'll just end
the quick poll quickly in 5 seconds so 5
4 3 2
1 okay let me share the results as well
so uh as we can see that uh
the highest number of votes we have
gotten for the first option here uh
enhance my interview skills specific to
blockchain position so that's great you
are in the right place at the right time
and the second uh highest vot we have
gotten for master effective strategies
for answering blockchain related
questions that's that's amazing and I
can see 32% of the folks have also voted
for tailor my responses to diverse
blockchain interview trips uh and I can
see few of the folks have voted for
navigate challenging blockchain
scenarios and impress potential
employees so thank you so much for
sharing that with us this is this
basically gives gives us a better
understanding on what exactly are you
looking for when attending this webinar
so now let's start with the interview uh
prep here so we'll be talking about how
you can crack the code on how to Ace a
blockchain interview for Success uh now
starting with the uh skills here what
are the skills that basically require
for a blockchain expertise uh Vish as
you can see we have so many skills here
on the screen here maybe can you tell us
a little bit about few of them to start
with when you're basically aspiring to
become a blockchain expert yeah rasham
so uh coming to the blockchain expertise
uh there you can see around 10 skills
over there but uh with starting of the
blockchain career uh all 10 skills are
not necessary you can start from Basics
itself like uh you can take Bitcoin
Bitcoin is the first blockchain out
there in indust
and then you can uh after Bitcoin you
can go to the consensus how Bitcoin is
working and what's the mechanism how the
blocks are mind and you can start you
can go with blockchain as well so
blockchain and Bitcoin basically bit
blockchain comes from the Bitcoin itself
so you can uh basically the topics are
like cryptography and cryptocurrency and
they are heart of the Bitcoin again so I
would prefer cryptography and
cryptocurrency uh and Bitcoin coin
blockchain Consensus These are the uh
basic uh Concepts to become stronger so
that these are the main questions that
you are going to face in any interview
uh if you go to any uh company out there
like you can go to Startup you can go to
any mnc's uh these are like basic
questions like that you're going to face
okay uh that sounds a lot interesting I
think we'll cover a lot of these uh you
know like skills right in the upcoming
interview questions right we talk about
more about that so now that we' have
talked about the skills uh these
blockchain skills open so many career
paths uh when we think about blockchain
you know someone who basically comes
from a non-blockchain background has no
clue about blockchain you think of
becoming a blockchain developer right
but there are so many career paths they
can take up right so maybe can you tell
us a little bit about few of them here
what career paths you know uh basically
someone can take up yeah uh starting uh
you can uh basically there are uh major
major of students in our uh you can see
in our webinar is like from the students
right majority of the participants are
students so basically uh they can go
with the blockchain developer right
blockchain they can start with
blockchain develop blockchain developer
as an intern and they can come to the
blockchain developer the one who is not
uh into the coding much they can choose
a blockchain quality engineer as well
but they should know the basics of
blockchain so they should be strong how
the blockchain works and how to interact
with the blockchain the core of the
blockchain the cryptography thing and
you can uh the people who are already
experienced uh in web2 space like uh
working on web2 applications they can go
with the blockchain solution architect
anyways uh everyone uh these roles are B
belong to the blockchain right so
everyone needs to know the basics strong
they should be strong at Basics and then
they can apply the Knowledge from uh the
uh previous experience or from their um
learnings uh thank you so much for
taking us to the career paths here so I
think let's move on to the interview
questions right I think we have few
selected interview questions which we'll
be taking up uh and uh let's start with
the first one here so the first one
first interview question for the
blockchain interview here is how do you
explain blockchain technology to someone
who does not know about it
uh yeah basically there are if you see
the uh blockchain literacy in uh world
right now it's around 1% of the total
population so it's so difficult to
explain what is blockchain yeah exactly
what blockchain is so we need to
basically relate them with the current
scenarios M so uh you can see the
example here blockchain is basically
distributor liser like I can give one
more example like it's an
uh your bank transaction passbook M so
you cannot change that right yeah so uh
let's go to First example uh here it's
given that uh school report card so
blocks are like the uh Student Records
like name of the student and details of
the student there and immutable uh
student cannot do that only teachers can
uh basically once marks are given like
once uh you will be having uniti
quarterly half a in your school so once
half is done you cannot change that yeah
blockchain uh follows that immutability
rule you cannot change data once it's
written on the blockchain oh interesting
yeah coming to the ownership uh only
specific people who the person who has
private key and public key you'll be um
saying that private key can change the
data and public can read the data yeah
so in this case a teacher will be giving
the marks right so we can uh say teacher
is a private key here and the student
will be um looking over their marks so
that's a public key here and uh coming
to the security and right uh so data
Integrity no one can change data once it
written and it's visible to everyone
anyone can come and read that data
interesting interesting so I'm saying
the bank uh passbook thing so that's the
same thing uh when you do a transaction
you will be the user and bank will be
the private key there bank will be
updating your balance and you can read
your balance anytime okay I think I
think I have no clue about blockchain
that definitely explains uh someone who
doesn't know about it uh and moving on
to the next one uh so guys before we
move on to this question uh of interview
uh so if you have any challenging
interview question which you have faced
in the blockchain interview or which you
feel like okay this is something I won't
be able to answer if I'm aspiring for a
blockchain career you can let us know in
the Q&A box I see a few questions we
have already gotten actually related to
blockchain interview that's great we'll
take those in some time so moving on to
the next question here uh we have a
question like what are the different
types of
blockchain yeah uh so blockchain is of
three types mainly like we can do any
tweaks to uh existing blockchains but
there are only three types one is public
blockchain uh the second is private
blockchain and third is the Consortium
blockchain so public blockchain is
something that you can um heard
basically you heard Bitcoin is a public
blockchain and ethereum is a public
blockchain so what what does make this
public so public means that the names uh
name tells that um anyone can come and
directly use that anyone can go and mine
the blocks add the transactions to the
blockchain and uh basically they can
come and read the data without any
restrictions so coming to the private
blockchain uh this is also a blockchain
but this is uh basically you need a
permission to go onto it and read some
data basically if you want to do a
transaction you need some permission
without permission you cannot go and do
a transaction on the private
blockchain anyways uh private blockchain
uh data can be read once uh the public
uh when the noes give access to the
public M okay so basically you cannot
directly
so only design people are the permission
people can access the blockchain so
that's a private blockchain and
Consortium it's basically a set of
participants can access the
blockchain and uh everyone can uh
visible it basically that's this is a
combination of public and uh private
blockchain so there is an some
properties of public are uh inherited
like anyone can come and and access the
data and some properties of private are
uh inherited like uh you need permission
to add a node onto the basically to do a
transaction on the
blockchain awesome awesome that sounds
pretty interesting uh I hope that
explains uh basically what are the
different types of blockchain we have
let us know if you have any questions on
chat or in the Q&A box here we'll take
those questions in some time now moving
on to the next interview question from
blockchain uh what is the difference
between Bitcoin and ethereum I think
when you spoke about Bitcoin and
ethereum I did have this question uh so
can you tell us a little bit about
this yeah uh so Bitcoin started the as a
first blockchain in Industry so at that
time uh it's just an uh blockchain which
uh which is doing transactions like uh
digital currency transaction like we
call it
cryptocurrency so this is basically an
um giving and taking thing like I can
send someone one Bitcoin they can send
me one Bitcoin we we cannot interact
with that Bitcoin except doing a
transactions yeah so you can see it
stores value and it's a decentralized
currency it doesn't have any border you
can basically send to a person anywhere
in the
world you don't need any bank account
like you need to basically to open a
bank account you need a lot of process
right it's a one day process right now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so this is just like creating a
wallet like you can do it in two to
three minutes interesting yeah so it
works on in proof of work and this is
also very important thing uh we'll be
talking further so how blockchain works
that's a consensus algorithm is called
as proof of work okay and supply of
Bitcoin there are only 21 million of
Bitcoin in um this blockchain you cannot
have more than 21 million so that's C at
21 million so Bitcoin is so so valuable
when people are coming to the uh Bitcoin
blockchain so everyone buys it right so
when by said there are billions of
people uh India has 1.5 billion of
people right so if India come that's
very minor amount of Bitcoin if everyone
in India buy it so that there it's not
sufficient only 21 people can hold the
maximum of on
bitcoin yeah we see that so it's a so
expensive thing in cryptocurrency right
now yeah yeah yeah it is
yeah there's one limitation in this
Bitcoin so the ethereum is solving that
so that limitation is that we cannot
have applications on that basically we
cannot write any smart contracts uh the
custom Smart contracts on bitcoin so
ethereum has come in
2014 so this has uh bought the uh
flexibility to write smart contracts to
develop application
uh if someone know about Bitcoin you
have heard of Unis swap like you can
swap your
currency cryptocurrency so that uh
ethereum enabled
that so uh coming to the uh focus of the
ethereum uh this is where uh all the
blockchain developers got uh some weight
like from here uh the blockchain
developing uh blockchain got the
transformation The Evolution the
evolution started from
here so this is a new Evolution where uh
people started learning uh the solidity
thing developing new applications
running in uh new smart contracts on the
blockchain and uh this uh mining
algorithm started same as Bitcoin at the
starting proof of work and last year it
has migrated proof of stake since proof
of work is consuming lot of electricity
and power uh which is not not so
sustainable so they have migrated it to
the proof of check now ethereum is
sustainable coming to the supply chain
uh Supply limit there's no such limit
because ethereum is running a proof of
shake right when you say proof of check
uh that's a new algorithm where the bit
uh the ethereum will be mining like uh
it'll be giving continuous rewards so we
don't have any limit for uh this
and coming to the smart contract uh you
need to learn solidity uh to write a
smart contracts on this ethereum
blockchain so that's an very uh
demanding job right now we we call it as
blockchain
developer interesting interesting I
think blockchain uh Bitcoin ethereum
differences like thank you so much for
taking us to that uh let's move on to
the next question uh but before we move
on to the next question Vish would love
to know
uh what was the most challenging
question you have faced in an interview
while you were starting off giving me
these blockchain
interviews yeah uh when I started my uh
blockchain interview the first question
was like what's the difference between
Bitcoin ethereum that we have discussed
yeah yeah and then they asked me how
does proof of work works yeah so that's
basically the Bitcoin algorithm how the
blocks are mind on the
Bitcoin and what they have asked is like
uh they asked me to explain the uh
cryptography in this uh mining process
so that's my challenging thing so I'll
be discussing that as well awesome
awesome awesome I think that is the next
question we have how does the Bitcoin
work and how proof of works works so
please take us through that uh so
Bitcoin as I was explaining Bitcoin
works on proof of work right so at the
starting uh someone has should uh run a
um basically run in node we call them as
minus they do add uh data in form of
blocks you can see from minus it's
starting from the blocks so before uh so
minus will be on the uh blockchain and
they are ready to capture the
transactions and do add into the
blockchain so transactions are nothing
but uh I can send to a person X or one
Bitcoin right so that's a transaction so
that will be in a
meol where minus will cat that data and
they will add into the new
block there'll be a block puzzle to add
that uh that will be in cryptographic
hash where lot of computation power
needed to add that and once that uh
Block Puzzle is solved proof of work is
done and they'll be adding to the
blockchain and they'll be broadcasting
to the remaining
minus so one uh once remaining minus uh
get to know that uh this block is when
day once they validate the block the
hash the hash that generated by the
original minor then they'll verify that
and the process completes and the person
who added the block right he'll be
getting a reward for adding
that so uh I explain this uh basically
these are the strong uh Basics that
every person should uh need to be very
strong M like this is the first
blockchain mechanism that uh come come
into came into the
existence interesting interesting thank
you so much for taking us through how
does Bitcoin work exactly uh so like did
you get a counter question in any of the
interview questions you have faced maybe
related to this one as well like uh like
accounter question maybe how to face it
as well maybe you can help us with an
example for
that yeah so
basically there are many questions on
this like they can ask you the what is
the Fault tolerance Benjamin fault
tolerance and what is the 51% attack so
there are numerous number of attacks on
this blockchain so what is 51% attack
let me explain that so there are let's
suppose 100% of uh miners in the
blockchain so once 51% of the uh minus
except this is the block that is going
to be the next block that will be the
final block of the
blockchain if I own my uh 51% as my like
any malicious user only 51% of the
complete miners uh the notes he can do
anything right he can add malicious blog
without sending any 100 Bitcoin to
anyone or without receiving from anyone
he can basically add that I have got 100
Bitcoin from this this user M so
basically that's an attack right BAS
basically that's a cyber security attack
we call it as 51% attack in our
blockchain
terms so interes yeah I do take
interviews and I do ask same questions
similar questions interesting
interesting what do you look for in
those candidates do do you obviously see
yourself uh in few and what do you look
for you know like see I'm pretty sure
they can ask maybe obviously there are
few which they can answer you
technically right right the way you have
explained it to us but what is that it
factor or X Factor you look for can you
tell us about that when hiring I I see
the clearness of their answer and the
confidence they should be cool and uh
they should be uh clear what they are
speaking about yeah exactly I think uh
that definitely shows confidence and uh
moving on to the next question I think
this this one is also one of the
questions basically you have faced in
your most challenging interviews right
so what is hashing in blockchain
yes so uh many people skip this part
Bally this is the heart of the
blockchain so many people read uh the
Bitcoin
ethereum uh and how po p and p work so
this uh hashing is something that uh
basically this is an encryption uh you
can say encryption thing uh not an
encryption a part of encryption
encryption has a decryption but hashing
doesn't have
decryption so if you say hello world
this is a hash function when uh when you
hash this you'll be getting a 32bit
hash so 32bit hash that will be hash is
something that uh generating an
random uh 32bit value in a fixed uh
variables it's not going to be more than
32 bit you can give uh any value you can
uh give give a paragraph of a uh length
paragraph to the hashing function that
will give the fixed length of 1 32bit
hash so if something change in that hash
the ultimately the output will change if
you say hello world if you change that
Capital H to small H we'll be getting a
different
hash so basically these hash is like
stored in the blocks of the
blockchain and this is like uh the chain
of blocks where uh this hash is stored
in the next block as
well block so once the complete message
uh any small uh thing changes the
complete blockchain gets
invalid so uh starting I was saying that
the blockchain is immutable right so
this is the uh reason that no one can
change data with the in the blockchain
that that is already written on the
blockchain basically if you're write
today something like you have sent me
one Bitcoin tomorrow no one can change
that if tomorrow someone changes that
today what happened today from today uh
the transactions all are done from till
tomorrow that will be
invalid yeah yeah uh thank you so much
for answering that uh question uh moving
on to the next one uh we'll talk about
more uh questions from the Q&A box and
more questions we have you know uh for
interview success in blockchain uh but
to summarize a bit you know what are the
strategies for interview success in
blockchain can you take us through what
strategies you know they need to follow
you know in generally Yeah so basically
I was saying that right Basics should uh
should be so strong like they should uh
be very clear about the basics like
what's cryptography and what's
blockchain how proof of work Works how
proof of shake works and what's the
difference between proof of work and
proof of shake
uh these are all the basics thing so and
they should uh as you were discussing in
U last interview as well uh the resume
thing they needs to have uh the projects
like handson experience like if they are
ready with handson experience the compan
are ready to uh take you in they are
ready to Ely I think I think we'll be
talking more about those handon projects
uh they can basically add to their
profile as well right after we give the
program introduction so that's that's
pretty good yeah so it's a basically the
blockchain is very fast evolving the
blockchain what uh we have done last
year is very different from now yeah
yeah it is evolving right it is Bing
pretty fast I think it started long back
like with Bitcoin where no one was aware
of it and now it is as you said you know
it is capped right you know you cannot
have more than the these many ethereum
coins right or you know you can have
cannot have you that many currency it's
limited right so it is evolving pretty
fast and I think we are towards the end
of 2023 now I I don't I think as the
trend goes by uh we basically the future
what holds for blockchain is pretty
interesting actually and the career part
it will open
up yeah uh so you need to be stay
updated with the industry trends like
what blockchain is doing where
blockchain is uh moving around so now
the current trend is like tokenization
like we are tokenizing everything in our
world like if you say real estate you
can say supply chain you can say Minds
you can say the Arles
Collectibles the everything is tokenized
goal is also tokenized now you buy gold
tokens on the blockchain so that's a new
use case that we are working on and they
are live in other countries like
us so coming to the uh you need to have
problem solving skills that's an
important thing for any developer uh who
is trying to get into the software
industry so you need to have uh the
knowledge about data structures in
algorithms and how to solve a problem
basically so if I throw a problem you
need to uh think about
that so how to uh solve the problem like
in a minimal uh time complexity way like
the best uh
outcome uh like in your own Journey you
know of experience of blockchain uh we
have come so far like for these problem
solving skills what would you suggest
folks you know uh like what do you do
you know what did you do when basically
you wanted to improve your problem
solving
skills so problem solving skills are
like not by birth they do improve by
practice so daily I would recommend you
to start with the starting like doing
one programming from any of the out
there
like simply learn lead could uh you can
go with hacker rank also you can start
basic with one by one practice sessions
like solving small small
problems you will be seeing a lot of
difference if you do it for two months
you'll be seeing a lot of difference in
yourself uh before two months and after
two
months yeah and you should be a team
player like you should not go and fight
out there like you should respect
everyone and you should work learn from
your senior
so they are experienced right so you
should learn you should work with them
and you should give your Solutions also
if you have a better solution than them
discuss that yeah exactly so I think uh
there's a lot to learn definitely uh in
blockchain uh moving on to the I think
we have talked about the mock interviews
here how B basically they can practice
mock mock interviews you know basically
to be confident and to be calm I I told
you right so you should be cool in your
interview yeah so for that you need to
practice yeah exactly get you get better
with every interview right I think you
give right in your experience I think we
actually have cover that in the program
as well we give them this one-onone
interview service we're talking about uh
more much more uh so moving on uh so we
have talked about basically what skills
you can take up we have talked about the
career paths here uh so what basically
is stopping you uh from becoming a
blockchain expert so you can see a quick
poll on the screen here uh we want to
understand what is the biggest challenge
here um I'm pretty sure you're here
because you want to be a a blockchain
expert here uh you want to take up a
career in blockchain or you already are
pursuing blockchain you're very curious
about blockchain you're passionate about
blockchain uh what exactly is the
biggest concern here you can see this is
a multiple choice question so you can
select multiple options here because
there can be multiple challenges right
you might be facing we would love to
know this this will give us a bit
understanding what exactly is the
biggest concern here so as I was
speaking we folks have already started
sharing ing their challenges through
these polls here uh in case this does
not cover your challenge uh basically
while you're pursuing a blockchain
expert career or you are aspiring for it
you can let us know in the chat here or
you can let us know in the Q&A box as
well uh while we were doing the
interview pep questions uh I see a lot
of folks are leaving their questions on
the chat here so folks uh just go and
put down your questions in the q& box
that is just beside the chat box uh we
will be taking questions from there so
please do that for folks have shared
their questions on the chat here so
because your questions will pile up and
go basically up and we won't be able to
find it so we don't want to miss out
your questions we want to address all of
your queries so please do that uh and
while I was speaking I can see most of
the folks have already shared uh their
biggest concern here let me just quickly
end the poll thank you so much for
sharing that with us let me share the
results here so as we can see we have
gotten the highest amount of votes here
56% for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
uh we can see 44 4% of the wordss for I
can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum that is
definitely challenging to find um and we
can see we have gotten few of the vs for
uh my work schedule won't allow me
enough time for Learning and uh I find
it difficult to learn from prerecorded
videos so I'll just stop sharing this
and uh move on to the program
introduction here uh so the IAT conour
program uh in professional certificate
program in blockchain uh gives you the
comprehensive curriculum with an
industry aligned learning path here you
get access to integrated labs and
Hands-On projects of practical exposion
which Vish mentioned you know how
important it is you know to have that in
your resume we'll talk more about it in
the upcoming slides what projects you'll
be getting to add in this program and
also online virtual classrooms uh and
with peer and instruction interaction
and also flexible to fit your LIF skle
in St so in case you are a working
professional you can basically just go
and uh join this program and do it in
just by giving five to 10 hours per week
the program duration for this this one
is four months um and how basically the
program builds your blockchain skills
step by step let me take you through
that uh so it starts with orientation
session and uh then we start with
introduction to blockchain and Bitcoin U
moving on to you basically we'll get to
learn a lot about ethereum uh which I
think we discussed about you know one of
the most important questions in the
interview get asked in blockchain and
are you basically getting an
understanding on conscious and has and
uh you get to know about hyperledger
Fabric and smart contracts and networks
and we covered applications of
blockchain as well and ending it with a
blockchain uh Capstone project which is
very important we'll be talking about
more in the upcoming slide how does
having a blockchain Capstone project
helps the elective here is by I khur
Academy master class which which you
will be getting an access to uh the
elective here is optional it comes as a
part of the program uh we don't charge
anything extra for that it is up to you
if you want to take up this elective uh
moving on if you have any questions
about the program steps you can let us
know on Q&A box or chat here also
talking about the key tools libraries
and platforms you will be learning in
this program Bitcoin as V started I
started with that and multi-chain hyp of
fabric uh ethereum solidity and truffle
and many more tools like relase
platforms you know like that in this
program I'll be sharing the program link
on chat here in case you want to have a
thorough look uh you know about what the
program covers as well uh also in case
you have any questions you can always
reach out to us at ask us at simple.net
and uh have a question about the program
you can ask us in the Q&A box I'll help
you with that uh so I'm just sharing
those details here on chat uh also we
talked about the projects basically you
can work on and enhance your profile uh
while you're trying to get out there and
get job ready and get a basically a job
in blockchain as we can see the projects
which you can see on your screen here
which is covered in the program voting
with blockchain ensuring transparency in
trade F Finance transactions and the
third one decentralized patient record
storage and many more like that are
covered in this project uh so which I I
just have a question from the crowd here
so uh let's let's assume that I I see a
lot of questions folks are coming from a
completely different background and they
want to basically go into a blockchain
career right as you have mentioned
earlier so is having these projects with
you know real business implications uh
working on these projects getting that
real time you know hands-on experience
on a project how does it help when you
basically are going for these interviews
how does it help like showcasing these U
you know projects to your future
employees yeah basically that's a basic
thing Rasha like I take interviews right
I first see the projects like what they
have exposure on like what they have
worked on like uh I see that uh what are
the uh technical tools what they are
using on every project like if you say
voting in blockchain that that will be
via Sol smart contracts right so they
should know how to write the smart
contract on solidity and how to deploy
contract on ethereum and how to interact
with that so they might they should use
some ID like truffle or hard at so these
will help uh
the recruiters to understand better
about the uh the participant or the
student or the
interviewer so these will obviously add
wait to your resume and coming to if you
are ready with these we can have uh the
more uh exciting uh applications that we
are running on the main net or you can
say in
production terms we call it mainnet in
blockchain and we have to call it as
production so yeah so doing these set of
projects are definitely helpful and
using these you can enhance your
knowledge and you can basically do the
realtime projects as well on your own
you can do a freelancing thing or if you
are from a different background you can
come into the blockchain basically
blockchain is very young it's like uh
six to seven years old in in development
M no one has more than four years of
experience right now in blockchain so
it's right time to jump on the
blockchain development and I'm pretty
sure that's not so difficult to come
into the blockchain and there are many
out there like you can go to Legal side
of blockchain you can go to the
Consulting side and yeah you are all
welcome and blockchain I I am U very
surprised to see the blockchain industry
is so uh welcoming like they are very
helpful if you don't know anything there
are uh communities out there on Twitter
on Discord on telegram they are very
helpful and you can learn so much from
the people out
there uh I think uh first of all like I
think you correct that you know that
folks may only have like some four to
five years of experience because it
started like some four five years back
uh and also we the kind of questions we
gotten here from people who basically
have no experience in blockchain you
know that is surprising like we don't
get you know that question that many
questions you know that they have no
background in blockchain at all that
actually answers that right like you
know that basically why don't they have
any experience in blockchain so moving
on I think we'll take few questions in
upcoming slides uh folks like I can see
we have gotten a lot of interesting
questions in the Q&A box here and uh we
are very excited to take those questions
but before that let me take you through
uh the simply assess job assess service
which basically helps you with the job
search uh the simply uh learn job is
only for Indian Learners I have shared
the link on the chat here in case uh you
joining from outside of India you want
to check out the fee and the program
cohart and you know much more details of
what the program um so in this you get
free access to expert webinars with
career events with industry leaders
which is necessary right as V mentioned
learning from people who are already
experienced and you get the exposure
here and also option to choose from Real
World projects across Industries and
create portfolio of projects that is
really important which is covered in
this program as mentioned that
blockchain has been in this space for
only four to five years and U like
coming from a non-blockchain is pretty
normal and as the blockchain industry is
involving uh you know with every month
as we are moving on and the tools the
platforms are evolving as well so uh you
need to basically be equipped with all
the existing tools which have basically
come so far that is why we cover all
these tools libraries platforms and also
imply that in these projects which
you'll be taking up that you can add to
your portfolio so when you actually join
a job right as a blockchain expert or in
that career path you can actually take
up new tools or you know platforms which
you can basically learn from an
Implement for your business right I
think that is something very clearly uh
V has basically uh you know taken us
through also job assist Services we have
partnership with in jobs uh where you
get resume uh review services and also
you know you get interview prep you know
one-on-one interview prep services as
well which is very important like uh
like in my own experience you know like
visha has also shared that you get
better with every interview give right
and I think having a service like a mock
interview or one interview from this
program is like very helpful when you're
getting out there and giving interview
you know in basically a career path you
have basically never taken before you
know so that is pretty helpful and I
think someone asked about the
eligibility for this particular program
so I'll just take you through the
eligibility and prequisites as well uh
so you need to have a basic
understanding of mathematics basic
understanding of java is preferred uh
you need to basically have a bachelor's
degree with 50% marks or higher and no
work experience is required as as we
have mentioned that here it's pretty new
and I think even when you are hiring
right like folks come with basically
less than one year of experience or two
years of experience right uh they might
be coming from a mathematics or you know
a coding background might have some
knowledge of that right I think we have
gotten some questions related to that
maybe let's take few questions uh I'll
just uh I think I see one question in
the Q&A box uh V there are so many
questions in the Q box it will be hard
for you to find so what I'll do is I'll
just put that question on the chart for
you so I just put down that question for
you on the chat so you can read it uh so
uh this is from um this is from giri
Prasad uh so uh he says that I am a
student and have no working experience
in any domain and Frankly Speaking as a
fresher uh has the least chance of
getting hired so what is your take on
this to tackle this problem and make a
career in
blockchain yeah uh PR I'm sorry what's
the name of the student here gir Prasad
yeah gir uh so no need to worry about
that right everyone starts from zero
right everything starts from zero so I
would recommend you to start with the
basics of the blockchain how blockchain
works again like uh how coin Works how
ethereum works and what's the difference
between both uh the how hasing algorithm
work and yeah simply loar is providing
all those right uh so you can start with
solidity programming you can do some of
the real world projects you can showus
the skills and there are many companies
that are starting the blockchain wing in
their company if you see if you say any
MNC company you can say capj you can say
TCS you can say Vio everyone has a
blockchain wing and they looking for the
people out there so they are ready to
hire you and they'll be uh very they
you'll be getting more weightage there
out there you'll stand out of the group
when you have the uh real time projects
like if you have real experience in
coding and building the projects yeah
you'll have more age out
there uh thank you so much for asking I
hope that answers your question you let
us know chat here if you followup
question here uh I think we we'll just
take one more question uh so folks we
have a special duration with the Q&A
part but we're just taking as promis you
know few questions you know in between
the session so very similar question uh
from Rishi we have here uh I'm just
putting that on chat for you very
similar question uh so do freshers get
direct blockchain developer as a job or
have to work as a web developer the job
uh it's not like you can you will be get
if you want to get a d blockchain yeah
you will get that that you need to
Showcase your developing skills in
blockchain right so you can directly
that's no doubt in that you can directly
get a blockchain uh developer if you
want to do as a web developer you can
also get into blockchain field like
learning web 3GS how to interact with
the blockchain so basically the friend
end part it's like a web developer thing
right so that no one is going to change
that but you need to learn how to
interact with that blockchain so you
need to know uh how blockchain works for
that
thank you so much for answering that
rishik let us know in chat here if
answers your question and if you have
any further question for that giri
Prasad says thank you on the chat here
and rishikes also says yes okay awesome
awesome uh I think let's quickly take
one more question um I think this is
from Durga and I'll just put down this
question for you on the chat here uh DGA
says I'll just put it for everyone
actually so UHA says that I am um from
non IT background so I choose to become
a project manager in blockchain uh what
will be the interview questions I can
expect maybe we can help uh help you
know them with maybe one one question or
something you know which will help them
because U I can see DGA is coming from a
non IT background you know what is the
usual question you know they could ask
right you know someone who's trying to
transition their
career so coming to the transaction of K
DGA it's a basically no one is going to
give directly a project manager thing
like you need to start from uh the basic
thing like manager I don't know what's
your experience let's say like uh 3 to
four years of experience out there but
uh you need to start with the uh
assistant a manager thing like you are
from non8 background considering that
you are from non8 background you need to
know how again the same thing you need
to learn what how you need to know the
working of blockchain basically like
uh what are the deliverables like what
people develop in blockchain what how
blockchain works and you need to know
how to manage with clients right project
manager is someone who delivers the
project yeah manages project like you
need to guide your developers to what to
develop so basically I would recommend
you to uh go with the uh basics of the
blockchain and how blockchain works
and uh you need to know what uh people
develop like what are different
blockchains out there there are many
blockchains or the like hyper Leger
what's the architecture of you need to
know about architecture as well like how
hyper Leger development Works how the
ethereum development works this seems
like very similar to a product manager
right a product manager who actually
manages these uh you know for set of
basically Tech folks right in a company
similarly I think uh you know a product
manager who's coming from an experience
of you know from an engineering
background is considered to basically
have more understanding of you know how
how to basically manage uh these
Engineers right similarly I think as you
suggested actually knowing about
blockchain you know how it works uh
actually a little working maybe a little
bit in that as well will actually help
you know managing uh you know basically
projects in blockchain so I think thank
you so much uh for answering that that
was a really interesting question I must
say uh we'll take more questions uh in
the upcoming uh basically uh slides here
as we have special duration for the Q&A
part I see a lot of questions coming in
on chat here so please put down
questions in the Q&A box uh because
we've gotten plenty of questions in the
Q&A box folks we'll be taking questions
from there so please do that so we can
address all of your queries here uh now
talking about the IAT khur uh basically
professional certificate program in
blockchain uh so uh would you uh like to
basically enroll into the program uh by
IAT kpur here there's a quick poll
question here which you can see here on
the screen right now uh with the two
options yes or no so we have talked
about the skills we have talked about
the career paths we have talked about
the projects you can add through this
program to your profile I know basically
to Showcase to your future employees
where getting you're getting out there
you know trying to get a job in
blockchain uh there are so many career
paths you can take up in blockchain uh
and this program covers all of those and
a special basically certificate as well
by I can't for in blockchain so
definitely that will enhance your
profile if you are aspiring to be a
blockchain expert blockchain developer I
must say and uh I think someone has
replied on chat that they have already
studied this problem so that's great so
interesting interesting to have an elim
here with us so someone who basically
has already covered blockchain and also
uh while basically you are actually
sharing your response here on the poll
here so about the enrollment here we
actually have a special bonus software
for the program uh for attending this
webinar uh and uh you can basically
Avail it by actually answering yes to
this particular poll of enrollment here
so let us know would you like to enroll
into the uh professional certificate
program in blockchain uh by IAT kpur
here so uh as we move on we have a lot
of questions lied up in the Q&A box and
we'll be taking those questions pretty
soon very interesting questions very
diverse questions we have and uh we have
taken few questions here uh till till
the basically webinar so far we have few
minutes left but we'll try to cover as
many questions as possible as we have
promised you uh before starting of the
session so I'll just keep this poll
alive for 10 seconds more so uh this
professional certificate program in
blockchain by I Kut uh as we have
mentioned covers all the skills all the
career paths which basically opens up
you know after taking up this program
the job assess Services by simply run
which basically provides you resume
review service and rewrite Services the
job uh basically you know get ready
service by oneon-one interview service
you'll be getting from the job assist
Services by simply learn that is also
like you know one something you know to
get hands on and also so many different
projects handsone projects Capone
projects you can add to your resume to
enhance your profile coming from a non
blockchain backgound so I think I'll
give five seconds more for this poll and
then we will end this poll um so five 4
3 2 one and let me quickly end the poll
and while you guys were sharing your
interest we saw a lot of interest
towards enrollment so that's great we've
gotten a lot of passionate folks here
about blockchain so I think we have
gotten one question in the Q&A box here
about the program fee and schedule when
when is upcoming next cohart here so uh
the program fee for this one is 1 69,000
including taxes uh this is an INR in
case you want to basically check out for
your own region because we saw a lot of
folks have joined from outside of India
as well you can basically check out for
your own region through this link uh
towards the program of sharing here on
chat so you can check out the link here
and uh to professional certificate
program in blockchain by it khur uh also
uh we have financing option options
available here as well uh so it is as
low as
5,751 uh rupees per month uh the cohard
for this one which is starting uh in
18th of November the classes will start
at that time and the induction for this
will start by 29th of October this is
the most recent upcoming cohort and also
folks we only have some 25 to 30 seats
per cohort we take up uh for this
program and want to make sure that you
know getting all the attention that is
required uh while basically you are
basically attending this program and
aspiring to become block expert and also
as I said that you know if you have any
questions you can always reach out to us
at ask us at simple.net
uh I've shared that email ID before on
the chat here I'll just share it once
again in case you have any questions
please do reach out to us now for folks
who have already shared uh basically
when do they plan to uh basically enroll
into this program would will have to
know basic how soon do you plan to
enroll so this is for the folks who have
already shared their interest towards
enrollment and I saw a lot of you while
basically be voting for the poll there
uh so this is a quick poll here before
we move on to the Q&A part of the
session um the Q&A Bo like filling up as
we speak with interesting questions here
so this is just a quick PLL with four
quick options here uh basically we would
love to know when do you plan to enroll
so we can understand when to reach out
to you so um I can see the polls are
moving so there are four quick options
here the first one immediately second
one within three months third one within
six months and the last one more than
six months from
now awesome awesome uh I think folks
have already started voting in here let
me just quickly browse uh Mish also like
you know let's browse through the Q&A
box here and see you know what questions
we can take up um as well you know in
the Q&A part of coming next so I'll just
keep this PO life for 5 seconds more
because I see that most of the folks
have already shared with us you know
when do when do they plan to enroll just
a suggestion in case you're still
thinking about it you have not planned
it out you know like exactly what month
of the year you know on coming months
you know when do you basically you plan
to start I would just select within six
months or more than six months from now
so this way you will at least get to
keep the bonus offer for attending this
webinar uh which you can basically apply
to the program fees you know which we
have gotten here so I think I'll just
give five seconds more for the folks who
are still thinking about it uh uh
because most of the folks have already
shared their responses here so 5 4 3 2 1
let me quickly end the poll thank you so
much for sharing sharing that with us
now moving on to the Q&A part of the
session so I think let's see we the Q&A
box is completely filled with questions
here so what I will do is I'll put down
questions in the chat here uh whatever
questions we'll be taking
up okay let me just quickly browse
through the questions here and uh see
the questions here which we have
gotten okay I think we have gotten one
interesting question here V I'll just
put that on the chart for everyone here
for have to look at uh so this is by
Kumar Manu
and uh he's asking that any Gap in
professional career will affect the uh
getting job as a blockchain
developer uh Kumar um basically yeah
that would affect any job but you if you
have an valid reason for that Gap
basically that people consider that
right so that basically you need to have
uh the valid explanation for that that
that will not be in barrier uh in any
veloping uh field so coming to the
blockchain thing again uh the recruiter
sees about your experience your exposure
in blockchain like how well you can
deliver the projects how well you can
interact with the blockchain how well
you can develop the apps and
applications on the blockchain thing so
if you are very good in that yeah you'll
be in into blockch as a blockchain
developer uh thank you so much for
answering the let us know Kumar Manu if
that answers your question or if you
have any F follow question as well you
can let us know in chat here or in the
Q&A box uh I think the next most
interesting question we have here is is
is the basically question by Muhammad
Fazil Sayad I'm putting that on the
chart here for everyone to see uh so
Mohammad F say says that I have done
mechanical engineering uh but I want to
switch my career in the blockchain field
I only have one question can I have to
learn uh JavaScript or python uh Lang
which along with solidity to enter in in
the blockchain industry um Mohammad uh
so that's fine you can do any
engineering and come into the IT field
like into the blockchain field you can
switch your that's not an barrier so
coming to the programming languages like
you need to learn solidity that's for
sure and you need to uh know the
concepts of data structures and oops
like object oriented programming like
inheritance and capsulation overriding
you need to know overloading and
overriding you need to know the concept
of this and how to implement this in the
programming language like solid is just
a programming language like many others
out there but this is like in the
blockchain which will help us inter
interact with the blockchain and
integrate our application into the
blockchain so there's no need to learn
about JavaScript and python uh if you
are interested in the JavaScript part
you can learn JavaScript and web3js
basically that's a framework to interact
with the blockchain from front and side
you can have
that awesome uh thank you so much for
answering that and I hope that answers
your question please do let us know in
chat here Mohammad fil uh so interesting
thing we actually have alumni here with
us of the same course uh I'll just share
the question here on chat here it is
anjani kava and anjani is here with us
and sees that I've already have simply
learns uh IAT comple blockchain
certificate my uh cohort is October 22
and uh basically she's asking that what
are entry points in blockchain
Industry so basically you are already
ENT the blockchain industry indirectly
what's the name Rasha uh an anjani anani
so you are already inent the blockchain
industry uh basically you need to do
some projects like I I'm sure that you
have done projects you need to just
showcase into them into your resume and
um be strong with just uh brush your
basic skills and go ahead and U apply
for the
interviews awesome uh thank you so much
for answering that I hope that answers
your question anani please let us know
if you have a follow off question here
also uh like I can see like a lot of
appreciation coming also towards you
like this is a really nice session about
blockchain technology and uh I also I
think from the same person we getting a
question about the webinar certificate
as well for that I'll basically share
towards the end basically how you can
get that uh moving on to a few more
questions we have extended four minutes
of the session but we can take maybe
like few more minutes you know to answer
a few questions
uh okay let's let's just uh quickly
browse more questions
here okay uh I think we have one
question
here so what is the correct way for a
finance no coding person to get into
blockchain internship or a job and
briefly explain the path or way again no
coding okay no coding specifically no
coding once again specifically there are
many things out there like you can go
with the architecture part like you can
be a blockchain architect if you say you
don't need any it stuff but you need you
need to know about the
features uh like what you can deliver to
the client then you can become business
analyst in blockchain field like you can
directly you need to be able to uh
convince client that I'm going to
deliver this in your blockchain project
or blockchain application so you can be
uh a business analyst out
there so that will be a best fit for you
since you are from the finance
background I'm suggesting you the
business analyst in the blockchain so
even for that you need to know
blockchain right what's exactly
blockchain and how does blockchain works
and what you can deliver to the
client uh thank you so much for
answering that visha I think U so we
have exchanged the session already you
know by some time uh just to address you
know most of your queries we have gotten
here I think we'll just end end it here
now because we have already extend the
time here so I'll just take a quick poll
question here about the program uh so
for folks uh who have already shared
their interests towards the program and
also have let us know when do they plan
to enroll uh this is a quick pool just
to understand if you need assistance
into enrolling to the program so uh
basically once your application is
reviewed uh your basically uh
application basically will be getting
shortlisted and the learning Consultants
from Simply will be contacting you with
an admissions offer letter and also with
the bonus offer for attending this
webinar so uh like I would suggest that
you know you can just quickly go and
share share us a response for for the
poll here that if you need assistance
into enrolling to the I conuts
professional certificate program in
blockchain okay I just give 10 seconds
more uh because I can see folks have
already started sharing their responses
on the poll here and uh also like uh for
folks uh like thank you for being an
amazing audience we have gotten so many
interesting questions here we took
throughout the session and I saw a lot
of folks who are basically passionate
about blockchain so uh thank you for
that and let me just quickly end this
poll here because I can see most of the
folks have already shared the responses
here so I'll just end this in 5 seconds
so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll
and thank you for sharing us with that
so now we towards the end of the
session uh I first of all I would like
to uh thank uh visha you know for first
of all taking the time out uh and taking
us through you know uh your journey of
interview experience and the most
challenging questions you have fa
especially you know and sharing that
with us you know with with confidence
and Clarity we could we could see you
know like you know how you actually
would have as that interview and also
taking us through a lot of things you
know uh basically pay Forks can take up
in career Vice blockchain skills they
can take up and so many questions we
have answered throughout the session
thank you for addressing and also you
know staying a little extra uh you know
till the webinar time uh would you like
to say something to the crowd here
before we end the session and also how
was was the session for you how was the
crowd for you because I saw a lot of
engaging questions in you know in the
chat box and I see a lot of appreciation
also coming in while you were speaking
as well for you so would you like to say
something uh to us before we leave yeah
uh that's an uh great uh participation
out there uh I see many people from
outside India as well so yeah I would uh
basically say one thing like blockchain
is uh very welcoming space to everyone
uh it's a a right time to get uh into it
and I would basically say you do with
the problem solving skills every day I
would repeat that uh you can go with the
quantitative analysis as well take any
Quant analysis question and try to solve
it think about that so your thinking
power will be uh improved gradually you
can see that day by day so if you are
doing that you can if you're solving
question 30 minutes today you can be uh
doing it in 25 minutes next month but uh
that's true and I have practiced that so
um please practice uh the problem
solving and learn about blockchain
blockchain is evolving so fast and
please be updated about that and you are
welcome to the blockchain space yeah
always uh thank you so much
once again for being an amazing speaker
here and teaching us to you know
blockchain interview tips and career in
general and again like thank you so much
for being an amazing audience here we've
gotten a lot of amazing folks here who
are basically curious about blockchain
and career in general so thank you so
much folks be ending the session now uh
please let us know on chat you know how
do you like this session and now I just
address the question about the webinar
certificate uh and the feedback
basically link so basically when I end
this webinar right now uh you can
basically we'll be seeing a post webinar
survey uh basically where you can
basically enter your full name for the
webinar certificate uh for you to get it
personalized with your full name and
also like you know feedback as well we
have many options there as well you know
how we can make it better uh all these
topics and area areas of Interest which
we cover in these webinars I've also
shared a link here there are a lot of
webinars happening every day here uh
with different different categories of
interest and also blockchain upcoming
webinars here as well so you can go and
check out this link of resources which
I've shared here and check out the
upcoming webinars you can register for
and also we would love to see visha once
again you know come in upcoming months
of webinars for blockchain and have an
interesting session with you uh for the
evolving uh blockchain uh industry in
2024 as well you know so we have
something interesting coming up and we
would love to see you again so thank you
so much thank you once again we'll be
ending the session now thank you so much
everyone thank you thank you folks
bye
I